here we go all right guys i keep
forgetting to hit the record button on
this on this mic thingy it's this new
new stuff hey guys what are we watching
erin
we're watching umbrella academy season
three episode two that's right let's get
this over quickly leave a like please do
it because i'm shooting this intro three
times in a row because of my own
stupidity and subscribe and click that
notification bell get notified
when our next reaction for umbrella
academy is up here on the channel also
full length watch long so you sync up
with the time code available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
and over there we cover many shows with
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included
lastly then boys at prepper thank you
for helping us edit down these
highlights real lastly thanks to today's
video sponsor but more on them after the
reaction
let's get to it pipes
[Music]
lost his donkey
oh hmm
losing a pet hard feeling
a lot of birds
luther becoming smart there he is
there's that brain ears
[Laughter]
yikes
[Music]
you guys are real [ __ ]
they did say they're gonna go after them
[Music]
it's not a great look for you guys if
you're supposed to be the heroes just in
the middle of the park just beating up
some random guy running
[Music]
if she still has a daughter this makes
no sense
you would think five would have warned
them about how there's probably a
doppelganger of her out there you would
think well they weren't there for that
conversation no no
[Laughter]
it's mommy
mommy
[Music]
who the hell are you patrick
it's a different timeline woman
you're scaring her
something is wrong
really
so this is like a malevolent hotel
the kennedy six oh
interesting i made history
now she died the 80s
dang
that's tough especially for someone who
like was just like a couple days for her
yeah i know it's just happened dang
awesome a girl time for a new haircut
[Music]
give me the sad cut i talked to marcus
last night wait what you talked with the
enemy by yourself somebody had to do
something who elected you vania sir
victor
who's victor
ah
i am
it's who i've always been
is that an issue for anyone
no i'm good with it cool
really happy for you victor
well last time i checked you don't speak
for this
this is a perfectly acceptable time yeah
why don't you go tell that to allison
who's upstairs grieving her daughter who
doesn't even exist here not to mention
we've been replaced by a bunch of blobs
and cubes and birds and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's no apocalypse the sun is shining
birds are doing whatever the hell birds
do we're done messing with time
and i'm officially retired i get his
perspective your son stuffed three mini
muffins down his pants and this is a
buffet i can take whatever the hell i
want how about no physical assault
that's a shut up
and listen give me one of those muffins
until your mom gets back right but no
more doing dumb [ __ ] or else you and i
are gonna have a serious problem look at
me
uh what the hell ears leaking
oh it's his power
i forgot to pack my ear medicine
if i don't drain it
no thank you i'm ben
number two it is so good to see you
again buddy
why does everyone keep looking at me
like that
because you've been dead for 15 years
dead
what do you mean dead why are you so
eight right
god damn i'm so aggressive number three
alfonso
quattro
hey
hey i'm jamie
that's christopher of course number
seven
oh don't mind him he's in a bit of a
saucy mood dude
is he born a cube i think so
he's canada's mama cube it's been a
weird birth man we took marcus the last
time you saw him he was with your sister
which one the little one with big powers
bunya it does not sound like vania to go
and kidnap anybody
you know having said that i am usually
the last to know about these kind of
things
[Music]
if they have your guy i'll make sure to
send it back without a scratch all right
no harm no foul
before i forget
if you try to escape these birds
pack your eyes out make a nest inside
your skull why are you like this dude we
will learn soon iran
all in due time we will i just don't
like it
[Laughter]
this is not appealing
this is such a creepy ass hotel your
crickety-ass doors
briefcase
i'm gonna try and get it back
yeah i went to see him last night alone
what were you thinking
i needed to do something but sure not
number one didn't we learn this last
season we shouldn't go off and do our
own thing because that's how
conflict starts amongst the
group that's it don't all right listen
to me just shut up for two seconds okay
just two seconds
he's gonna try to find his guy because
he saved him from dying hmm
we
are going to pennsylvania to find
my birth mother oh
okay i was wrong i needed somebody to
come with me for emotional support oh
emotional support yeah schnauzer yeah
and i knew you wouldn't come if i told
you so i was like goddamn right i
wouldn't
[Laughter]
thank you for trusting me with this
your family
victor
and there's nothing
nothing that would make me love you less
this must have been very empowering for
elliot pitch everyone on umbrella
academy going we support you
i found a treasure trove of our family
history told and expired check stubs
[Music]
rachel
so this happens sometime during season
one
have you tried that no because my ears
all squirt juice every time i get
excited yeah then trust me i need my
brain
my brand
huh
[Laughter]
what's your power kid your mom and dad
are super what'd you inherit
you guys are [ __ ] what is this the
boys they like yeah
[Laughter]
well isn't this
the only thing i see is yours tough guy
you followed me
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
is it only the face
maybe
what dude your chin
does that sometimes
it does that sometimes what the hell
[Music]
okay so it's it's objects too
are you getting tired
getting weaker
even
so diego just used to the pain i guess
[Music]
oh her glance oh
oh disgusting
[Music]
oh good job kid
[Music]
he who fights and walks away lives to
fight another day okay
[Music]
i really like that yeah
i like that the messed up face guy a lot
he's an enjoyable character like the way
they flesh out his personality good luck
wait you're not coming
yeah okay yeah i can do that sure
shouldn't he not go here because of the
doppelganger thing in the first place
i'm looking for rachel hershberger
no rightfully okay well that's a shame
i thought you people were supposed to be
nice because you have ruined the amish
for me
why do homicides never have mustaches
or why they depicted never having
mustaches always trips me out that's his
mom right
i'm assuming
[Laughter]
if i could i'd get out of here in a
heartbeat
why
and i know there are better places out
there in the world and
one day i want to see them all don't
trust her i spend a little time on the
move
that is so cool
you think so
yeah
the moon oh my god no one ever thinks
that's cool
hotel downtown
the hotel
you're trying to honey trick me no no no
no of course luther you're so stupid oh
wow you really think the moon is cool
okay
we're having a good time okay she she's
either playing him or he's like she
actually likes him in the family well i
think she's really a sign to play him
but she's actually like him
who do you think you are morbius
[Music]
watching people from low angles
[Music]
no all the cows
[Music]
no
[Music]
what's going on what's going on
merge with it grace become one merge
with it
did they create an incursion where's the
illuminati you tell them you know rachel
don't you
she's my sister where can i find her
young man
she's been dead for over 30 years
how did she die
brain hemorrhage
when did she die again
she passed october 1st
1989. oh yikes it's my birthday
you need to leave me
unless that's rachel yes that is rachel
just changed your name
[Music]
you spent a whole year not really giving
a [ __ ] about that kid
he ended up in vietnam and i can't
handle another i swear to god and when
you came back in the timeline was
different you didn't think maybe that
wouldn't be there too didn't even occur
to you
but he's not a monster he kind of
murdered the bureau so
[Laughter]
why can't you just get along with people
i really i did i tried
hold on a second
rachel's death was unusual and and she
wasn't the only one come on
um
whoa
or never
i don't think i don't think it's called
a [ __ ] car goddamn class he's some
ghost or something freak him out
my mom died here before i was even born
how'd she die before he was born or on
the day he was born
didn't harlem have to have the the
headphone things on too it's probably i
think yeah i think it's definitely him
oh
ice powers
doesn't look like your family is coming
anytime soon oh no i'm sure they're just
you know working out the final details
traitor we're in sparrow merch
let marcus go and
don't forget that get that stick out of
your ass
jesus hope you enjoyed your stay
i like how he gets a tote bag
there is a boys like quality to them of
uh yeah very obsessed with branding
right not as messed up but still yeah
not what they perceive to be to the
public but they're not even trying that
hard to hide their real nature though
oh
oh
smart
she mirror powers she's clever girl
clever girl
i need to be able to react to danger on
a moment's notice
how am i supposed to do that when i'm
playing wetness to a 12 year old you're
his dad
alleged
at least you have a kid
you insensitive prick
[Laughter]
where's luther
okay
october 1st 1989. it's our birthday
anymore it isn't they all died before we
were born oh my god
whoa
i'm saying when we jumped here we
created a time paradox and not just any
paradox but this is the grandfather
paradox
they died were they killed by horograves
you think oh
maybe
[Music]
this guy's always getting the romantic
stories
things look so bad
[Music]
why is hardcore just like a normal old
man in this
time
my family
they're crazy
but i want to let you know i meant every
word i said about the moon
i love the moon
nice
he just said [ __ ] [ __ ] my sister hey
both
[Laughter]
[Music]
where's a candle when you need one
[Music]
okay i like that episode
way more yeah that was much better damn
yeah it was pretty good now we're
getting somewhere yeah that's pretty
damn good all right all right
ah more my jam yeah buddy all right
let's ch cheddar
ch
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
yeah i like that one way more than the
first episode by a lot like this is this
in some way should have just been the
first episode
[Music]
this is the umbrella academy we were
waiting for much more much for the jam
especially with like having an actual
mysterious intriguing plot there at the
end
with what um because i started clicking
for me what they were doing in the first
episode like yeah it's supposed to be
you know that everything is not as dire
consequences because
uh there's no apocalypse happening it's
fine everything's fine and i i really
got where five was coming from uh this
time around put me in a different
mindset with his character of guys i've
been fighting for years and years i grew
into an old man came back as a young boy
and i'm still killing and fighting
and this is the one timeline where it
seems like everything could actually
just be fine so it might not be what we
were looking for but it's gonna work
and you know him just trying to retire
and and find a new sense of
everyone's is kind of finding a new
sense of stability or purpose and a
point of existence in their life here
and so i really thought that like the
the setup they had at the end they're
like oh that's really interesting that's
really intriguing like what did happen
to them and you know what is this
exploding
alien thing that grace is becoming
subservient to uh down in the basement
you know it's there is something really
menacing about what's going on there um
and i i thought i i think everything
about this one was pretty pretty solid
uh all around i really liked uh and
what'd you think about like miguel and
ash
kids davis
i didn't i didn't get the kid's name i
thought that was fun you know i thought
like the the initial
premise of them like oh i gotta beat
that dude up in the the convenience
store was a little hokey but then the
execution of that concept was really fun
and really cool and i like to i liked
getting to see them bond and then them
[Music]
and then beat up each other uh and diego
just like immunity to pain apparently or
maybe that was something from before but
just seeing them interact was very cool
and then i'm still trying to understand
what the powers are on that guy because
i thought it was like an instant
deflection or reflection but then it
seemed like at times it wasn't happening
i think it was just diego hitting him
and then but diego just didn't have a
reaction to it but other times he would
have reaction to it so i don't know but
all i know is i was wondering if it was
just
uh like physically punching him but then
we saw when uh when when asked straight
through the knife uh it cut him and uh
in addition to cutting the guy he threw
it at so i was like okay interesting and
then yeah she really has like a almost
like a snake venom kind of thing
when she spits her
her black juice i do find you the black
juice uh i do has could sound like
something else
but i did i did like i think the added
the two personalities i think they're
the most intriguing personalities out of
the sparrow academy the ones they fought
in the convenience store yeah and i do
think that uh you know diego and ash
will learn his name eventually uh
asher's who played on on
euphoria yeah and uh i do think that
they have good chemistry like i believe
them as this like father and son like
their becoming father and son but i i i
see the dynamic i see the chemistry and
so i it really dawned on me there and i
liked the setup of diego being like
i promised myself i'd be a good dad but
she's kind of getting my [ __ ] way
right now
like he's going to
he is doing what our grace would do
and he doesn't even realize it they're
just like kind of being like short with
him and not taking the time and like
rejecting him you know he is doing the
stuff but in his own way right now
realizing he's doing it yeah so i think
that's really nuanced in the way that's
being fleshed out yeah you kind of take
on those things those those habits are
those traits of your parental figure and
i think them how they display that is
pretty clever and that's going to be
part of his arc and there is a
meta quality to the whole thing with um
victor the transition uh here you know
because
i mean i don't know like i i remember
season one uh vanya had a boyfriend
right yeah the whole thing is like kind
of like [ __ ] up guy yeah but i think
it was the whole thing about she went
her whole life not feeling validated and
invisible and the fact that this person
was manipulating her and and showing her
that she is seen which was what made her
attracted and i think that with uh
yeah and the first and yeah in that one
she felt seen and like understood but
he's really playing her but in the
second season she really found true love
and connection she found herself and
then realized that
she wasn't the person that she felt um
internally so yeah i'm kind of embracing
that and i really like to see that
for the most part from what we've seen
so far the family really embracing
victor and like that change they're like
really on board with it um pretty
immediately and i think that
you know
that family dynamic and then like them
not that not affecting their bond was
was something really powerful to see and
i think that's really gonna resonate
with some people oh absolutely i feel
like that that is a good way it's like
part of me goes i kind of crit cause i
have no issues with elliot page i really
couldn't give two shits oh my good good
for elliott paige um
uh but but there is that part i was like
i want a little bit of coffee i want not
a conflict but like some type of
tension from me yeah yeah i just i found
myself just kind of craving it because
it's it seems like the way they were
maybe this is my own projections
happening do you want around the family
like tension within the family of that i
don't even know if his tension but just
like a little bit of having to adjust to
it yeah everyone accepted really
everyone's like yeah elliott page the
actor
we're doing this for elliot page which
is cool like i think that's great
um i i think in terms of just the
writing of it and that's what i mean
over some of it starts feeling a little
bit meta because it seems like a big
thing they've now been inclusive about
in support of elliot page yeah so
there's i have no issue with that it's
really the
like
yeah but what i really respect though is
how
they are using you know the fact that
elliot page has now come out and they're
implemented into the character with
victor of because i don't know if that
was always a plan it doesn't strike with
that it was always the plan but
including that with the character of
watching
victor change as a person too more than
just
yeah
transgender got it you know new name and
all that and it's it's the fact that uh
victor
seems more self-assured more confident
like that is a cool way to portray
victor
uh and not just transition how
but also show no this is a different
person now and this person is much more
um
at ease with with oneself i think that
was great like that to me was more
powerful than them having to have a
scene
with like what what's going on here
you're well you always have been i don't
know i will say as we're talking about
it and it's making me think a little bit
more and
you know i i do
support and understand the the concept
of someone not feeling comfortable
within their own skin
um it all seemingly happened really fast
i'll say though if i'll say that's my
only thing i support the decision of
them doing it i think i would have liked
to have seen that be
uh vania's personal journey into
becoming victor instead of it just like
i'm gonna get a haircut hey i'm victor
now and everyone's like okay cool i
would have i would like to see some sort
of progression with that but that being
said
um well it seemed like it moved fast
because of the fact that like we know
elliot paige is is now elliot yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's [ __ ] wing anymore yeah
that's what it was i would say like
overall i i did enjoy the episode a lot
more um than the first episode that we
watched i will say i didn't love it
though i will say i had a couple issues
like i know that the character of ben's
supposed to be like you know it's not
the one that we're used to i just i
don't know what if it's like the writing
of the character the way he's performing
i just really don't enjoy watching him
on screen i think the acting and the
writing of the character is is not i
really liked ben a lot in the other
previous seasons yeah yeah the thing is
it just doesn't seem believable yeah
like he doesn't strike like he's too
angsty for no reason it just seems fake
it seems like he's feigning all this and
it doesn't seem purposeful that it's
supposed to be fake it doesn't yeah it
doesn't feel authentic
yeah none of it feels it feels like i'm
watching a performance and weird writing
yeah um
and
and uh and i don't even have like the
this like strong
like love for ben to care like i've
always really liked ben but i've never
had like this big fondness for ben so
it's not like i have a hard time
separating myself from that version that
has nothing to do with that it's really
just there's it seems false so it seems
fake yeah but you see like i i like this
episode a lot and there's a lot that i
and there's quite a bit that i loved
about it because i did feel some of that
suspense come in um eventually that that
is a big part of what gravitates one
towards this show you know we are
building up what lila's really doing i'm
getting a sense of mystery about this
hotel in some ways like i feel like it's
going to become something that's more
important
um i like five getting back into the mix
of it all
and and uh um
this stuff with um oh my god why alison
um with allison yeah you know it's like
i had to move past it pretty quick
because it was really obvious that her
kid wouldn't exist like no [ __ ] you
didn't even bother to question it yeah
that's that's what i was talking about
in the first episode like
obvious questions that
should be risen up like as a natural
result of the event of the story
but characters don't counter those
realizations because we need plot to
unfold that being said i didn't care for
how it unfolded initially but the fact
that she's going through some like
distortion mental thing i think that's
pretty interesting and i'm curious to
see what that evolves into and i liked
her scene with victor quite a bit i
think the way they handled that was a
really great way to to do it because
yeah i think there was
i felt less awkward to me yeah the first
scene for like it was really awkward we
accept you elliot
exactly exactly okay this is this feels
like
like a writer mandated into this yeah i
feel like we're now watching a
behind-the-scenes decision tonight
the second one felt really authentic i
was like
i was just like
okay all right yeah yeah yeah
but yeah like i said i really support
the decision i like the fact that both
the character and the actor are doing
something with and that's more
comfortable than their skin because i
think uh i did like the way they had
they transitioned out of it they were
number five i like be happy for you
victor you still shouldn't be doing this
[ __ ]
that was like a really great transition
to him we accept you but
no no you're number one
i really loved i really loved luther a
lot in this episode though that's
something i genuinely loved like it's
always great i like the twists of the
the unveiling of him like really
this sparrow academy is all right i
really enjoyed his performance a lot
here and um i do find his ca i don't
know how you i'm gonna make some signals
from you about it uh the the the uh what
is what is that girl's name sophie
so
sloan sloan sloan um uh yeah i actually
buy their chemistry a lot i've always
thought the allison thing was a little
weird
no i was just i was just kidding yeah
no i was obviously don't [ __ ] your
sister wherever you are
no no i just thought it was happening a
little fast but that being said i buy
the chemistry and as the scene played on
i was like okay it's the whole thing of
like she's the she's like the
pure-hearted one of the group of like
crazy people and they're
they're bond it makes sense i believe i
believe their chemistry i was just i was
just a little suspicious because i'm
just suspicious of characters yeah as my
first meet them but you know i think the
i'm curious to see how that unfolds and
the tension between these two rival
families and how that's gonna play out i
like that we're finally getting to the
mystery of what's what's happening i
think that's when this show worked
it took a while
that's when the show works at its best
when we're seeing these characters that
we enjoy involved in this mystery plot
of what's actually going on yeah it's
like the first couple seasons got there
pretty relatively quick yeah to hook you
you know like what was the first season
the death of hargraves right
yeah that's what brought them all back
to the house the death of hard graves
and then this season and the second one
was like we're trapped here in the
sixties another apocalypse and this one
with and they had to find each other
this one took a while it was just like
okay we've created an ultra timeline
here's why hargreaves did it and then
now we're just adjusting and and uh yeah
this one took quite a bit to get going
but now that the mystery i'm like oh
finally parker hargreaves seemed
suspiciously normal to me in this season
like what threw me off in the the last
episode when number one was like doing a
speech and he was like sit down i'm like
hargraves listen to him i was just like
i thought he's like the actual leader of
this group so that was odd that he's
kind of he's a little more like it's
kind of the demonstration of what makes
the sparrow better as he could be at
ease
that's oh that's true maybe that's kind
of how it looks
i can see that that like i do miss the
hard ass hard graves
yeah the one who's a little bit more
involved in the mix of crime fighting
but everything is you know like they're
the heroes the sparrow academy's loved
every morning number one goes out there
works out and throws something to the
crowd you know
throws this wet his sweaty ass towel and
they all go crazy the only thing i'm
concerned about is the fact that
they're kind of dicks in public but like
but they're also beloved kind of how
we're talking about during the episode
they kind of have like a thing similar
to the boys and i'm like does nobody see
the like the
the stuff they do in the streets and
like they just like totally just like
picked on a dude running and just like
put them upside down in the middle of
this public park i was like all right a
store that let them go
huh in the store you know when she's
like just munching on candy yeah exactly
yeah stuff too
um well i mean
similar to the boys i think what they're
doing is slowly peeling back the layers
showing that nah they're all kind of
messed up yeah yeah
we need to find out what's happening
with ben now because jesus that boy is
unbearable
i think it's just the writing and acting
like
it's not meshing yeah yeah hopefully
that onion gets peeled back we
understand what took place in this
universe at this timeline to make him
that way yeah yeah um
yeah i know it does always strike me it
pulls me out of return like you just
don't seem real
yeah but i will say that
the mystery this season is really
intriguing the fact that they uh
the all their moms died before they were
born so like okay we kind of did they
not exist i'm assuming that's the case
because then with the dis that um
throws away the
the obstacle of running into
doppelgangers because all their moms
died before they were born it says yeah
that flashback we were seeing with klaus
that was before all this right i see
what happened season one yeah or or
within that time frame yeah because his
hair seemed like it was short and a
beanie yeah yeah
also why would he have the checks of the
people he paid off if they died
in this universe yeah yeah exactly yeah
i know what you're saying so yeah that
must have been and he's just been
holding on to that in his shoe forever
exactly and now here he is um
i covered i i appreciate that uh quite a
bit and i feel like there's i mean this
whole thing with grace i like that
they're keeping her a little bit evil
uh or mysterious in what they're doing
but i think we covered everything so far
right yeah
they
episode three but she's she's there
she dropped off her kid last episode and
know she's just she's struggling to get
back home or wherever she's trying to
get to yeah i guess the mystery build-up
has just been taking a little bit of a
while for everything to feel truly
intriguing
in terms of like hook me into wanting to
know how this is gonna unfold right but
this is why this is all released at once
because yes
most people will not take the time to
just slow down and think one episode at
a time
exactly
because but i think like the last season
works so well one episode at a time
where i'm like oh i feel like i kind of
have to binge this yeah we're going to
appreciate it yeah
um all right guys well leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like and last but not least
this is a pie
trend michael linden
mikhail
i just checked our email
and
you increased your pledge
after all this time you've been with us
you just suddenly increased your pledge
dude
you're full
egypt oh why would you do such a thing
oh my god oh my god you think what do
you think we would really oh my gosh
stuff for
we're gonna benefit immensely oh my
goodness but like an anti-discount but
dude you're just just like wasting money
man just wasting it
yeah you're a you could be investing
you're a sucker you don't no finance how
they do this in sweden
oh that's embarrassing man dude and a
new one isn't very that's how you go
broke yeah dude
no refunds
no refunds no refunds no refunds no
refunds but you can write this off as a
charitable donation
i mean
dude that's so kind of you after so long
to be here didn't suddenly increase your
pledge like that it's another how much
likely you waited that i couldn't even
keep a straight face that is so
embarrassing
silly why would you do that so silly
embarrassing michael hey i'd hate to be
you oh i'd hate to see the look on
everybody never gonna see that money
back
[Laughter]
this is the one show it to you
all sincerity that's pretty
that's really generous of you we look
good you've already you've already
contributed so much to our patreon
that's a staple to then suddenly
increase your pledge after all this time
when we haven't even had been so busy
haven't really had a chance to interact
um that means a lot so thank you for
being you all this time
you sucker
i never know i never know what the truth
is anymore
thank you thank you seriously thank you
[Music]